House Democrats are accusing president
Trump of abuse of power and obstruction
of Congress but isn't that exactly what
Nancy Pelosi is doing by refusing to
send impeachment articles to the United
States Senate Democrats from the start
have been saying this had to be done
immediately the Trump administration is
supposed to do horrible danger to our
country our values our people and our
reputation that trump presidency poses a
clear and present danger to our country
and to the world
this Ukraine allegation is
head-and-shoulders one of the most
serious and urgent allegations that we
have seen so the timing is really driven
by the urgency joining me now is tom
Fitton the president of Judicial Watch
along with John Eastman Claremont
Institute senior fellow in
constitutional scholar John I want to
start with you because you're actually
the one that pointed out the wording in
the resolution passed in the house this
is House Resolution number 755 and it
says that Donald John Trump president of
the United States is impeached for high
crimes and misdemeanors and get this
part folks and that the following
articles of impeachment be exhibited to
the United States Senate
now John doesn't that mean exactly what
it says I the Democrats wrote these
articles they are solely the ones that
pass them and now they're not actually
abiding by them correct well that that's
right and Nancy Pelosi seems to think
that because if she were to have another
vote that says don't send them over to
the Senate she would probably get a
majority on that as well that we don't
actually have to have that vote we can
just deem it as having been accomplished
like they tried to pull back with the
Obamacare legislation nearly a decade
ago
no the House of Representatives operates
by majority vote as a body no individual
member of the House of Representatives
has any power different than other
members even the speaker and when they
pass a resolution that says it shall be
exhibited to the Senate that's the law
there's no further action necessary and
now we're an unsure
territories but quite frankly if I were
Senator McConnell I would say it's
exhibited to the Senate I've read it in
the congressional record we're gonna
take it up next week I don't know if
they can actually do that but I do find
an interesting Tom that here they have a
chance in Tom's joining me on set here
in Washington they Pat they write these
articles they pass them themselves
what's your take on it well they don't
want to lose in the Senate they're
trying to put off the loss even a trial
that's abbreviated or a trial that has
witnesses they're still going to lose
and they don't want that to happen
and obviously seeing a new opportunity
well maybe they can play the game
through the election have Perpetual
impeachment of the president and the
problem is the Constitution and the
president has civil that always gets in
the way right there's a rule of law
thing called the Constitution you know
and I've always called this a coup and
you see elements of it with the
impeachment obviously was based on
nothing so abusing their rule of the
powers they have under the Constitution
to impeach the president by pitching him
for nothing and now they're trying to
overthrow the Senate and they want to do
a if they don't get there they're
Cavanagh type hearings against the
president they're trying to blow up the
legislative branch as well and if I were
and if I were Mitch McConnell I'd say we
we're gonna run a trial here now Pelosi
and the rest can it participate or not
but we're gonna run the trial and
frankly to the degree there's going to
be a trial it should be of Adam Schiff
and his prosecutorial misconduct there
should be no full-blown trial why would
why would you reward the cuckoo ball
with an abuse of trial of the president
yeah John how does the president get due
process I mean they have been throwing
allegations at him since day one Nancy
Pelosi admitted she finally said look
we've been working on impeachment for
more than two-and-a-half years that says
a lot now they're off on a recess how
does he and as the president it actually
get due process in this case well well
this is one of the very reasons that the
office of legal counsel has for decades
under both administrations said the
president can't be indicted while he's
in office because they couldn't bring a
trial against him and in an indictment
hanging over his head while he's in
office that he cannot vindicate himself
against would the
residency the the office itself well
what Nancy Pelosi is doing here is
exactly the same thing and in the
parallel with the first article of
impeachment that they are using the
powers of their office to try and
investigate the head of the opposing
political party who happens to be down
at 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue what they
are doing with the impeachment itself
much less fruit the holding now the
articles of impeachment and not sending
into the Senate is an utmost abuse of
office it really is a travesty and it
just shows you how blindly how blinded
what how much blind hatred they have for
this president that they're willing to
throw off every norm in our institutions
in order to try and find some dirt on
this president to get him out of office
yeah now Tom what's interesting me going
back again to that pesky you know
constitutional question I think I saw a
Donald Trump jr. post this up what Nancy
Pelosi is really wanting is a quid pro
quo I'll send this over if you do this
which is kind of ironic and in the whole
thing but the Constitution says that the
Senate has the sole power just as if as
the house had sole power to move forward
articles of impeachment the Senate has
the sole power that's a problem for
Nancy Pelosi isn't it it is and that's
why she's trying to leverage the timing
of delivery of the impeachment articles
there's nothing in the Constitution
about the house delivering articles with
impeachment you know they impeach him
and then the Senate takes up the trial
and if I were Mitch McConnell I would
just acknowledge the reality and take
the president out of this constitutional
limbo remember the president is being
victimized here he needs to do his job
he's tweeted that it makes it more
difficult for him to talk with foreign
leaders and we don't want the Congress
in a tyrannical fashion blowing up the
Constitution just for political purposes
you know and I've half jokingly say this
but you know Mitch McConnell famously
and correctly in my view put off the
confirmation of Merrick garland during
an election year and I think the Senate
should think about putting off any
impeachment trial of the President or
some merrily dismissing it because we're
not doing it in an election year now
that's that would be an interesting take
on it now John a real quick
we've only got a few seconds left but
there is some talk that the Democrats
would actually delay this until after
the election and then want to bring up
these same articles again in between
that time of the election in November
and when a new president or the
re-election of Donald Trump happens is
that can they do that so so the right to
have council president your hearings the
right to confront witnesses against you
and now we'll throw in the double
jeopardy clause in our in our in our
Sherman s blow through the
constitutional norms of Criminal
Procedure look it's not just the present
this president who is who is being
victimized here it's the Office of the
President itself that is being
undermined and and it's a great
detriment on our on our ability to
conduct government both home and abroad
well but the Democrats have demonstrated
in full force that they're really not
interested in getting much done Tom I'll
give you the last 20 seconds here where
what do you think is gonna happen when
they actually reconvene here the first
week of January well will you see a
hardcore senator leftist senator
Blumenthal say I think we're going to
get this quickly Pelosi you may have
over overreached here and I think
there's going to be some type of trial
where there's going to be an
adjudication that will ultimately
vindicate the president look the only
Nancy Pelosi I know she pull tests
everything and does focus groups on
everything and I think that's probably
what's going on right now I'm just
guessing
through experience John Eastman and Tom
fit and Merry Christmas Happy New Year
thank you so much for joining us tonight